hi I'm Deborah Fisher and I'm a
professor of astronomy at Yale
University my job is to find planets
orbiting nearby stars and today we're
going to introduce a new project for you
called planet hunters in our solar
system there are eight planets that
orbit our star the Sun we've been
detecting planets orbiting other stars
as well since 1995 more than 500 planets
have been found orbiting other stars
there are a few techniques to find
extrasolar planets planets orbiting
other stars the technique that I use is
called the Doppler technique and
basically as the planet orbits the star
it causes the star to wobble around a
common center of mass with the planet so
we can't see the planet with my
technique but we see the star wobbling
tortoise and away from us another
technique is called the transit method
and with this method the planet passes
in front of the host star and causes the
Starlight to dim ever so slightly it
takes about three hours for planet to go
across the face of its star and so for
three hours we'll see a little dip in
the brightness of the star you can
imagine that if the planet is very large
the the depth of that transit will be
much deeper
in March of 2009 nasa launched the
kepler mission the principal
investigator bill berukhi had been
planning and working to design this
mission since the mid-1980s and so it
was an enormous feat when it finally
launched the great thing about Kepler is
that because it's above the earth's
atmosphere it gets a very clear view of
the star field so Kepler is staring at a
field of stars near the constellation
Cygnus where there are two hundred
thousand stars in this field and
unblinking the telescope stares at these
same stars and watches takes
measurements every 30 seconds and
watches for a slight dimming in any of
these stars as a planet passes in front
of it with Kepler we hope to determine a
tissy birth the frequency with which
earth-like planets form
the first data from the Kepler mission
has been made available to the public
and astronomers have been absolutely
amazed by what they're seeing the time
series snapshots of stars that are taken
by Kepler is called a light curve so
we'll see the changing brightness in a
star either because a planet is
transiting in front of the star or
because the star has spots or because
the star is expanding and contracting or
because there are flares on the star and
it's the unprecedented precision of the
Kepler data that is absolutely blown
away astronomers as soon as we saw the
data we realized that this would be an
interesting experiment for the citizen
scientist Galaxy Zoo was the original
citizen science project where we took
images taken by a robotic telescope in
New Mexico at Apache point which had
taken data for over a million galaxies
the problem was no one person or even
team of scientists was able to really
sort through all of them by hand and
take a good look at what was out there
in recent years data sets that
astronomers and other scientists have
been working with have gotten bigger and
bigger and so the old techniques of
getting a few scientists together to
sort through it by hand have been
getting harder and harder what many
scientists do now is they just run
sophisticated computer programs one
computer can only ever look for what you
basically teach it to look for and so if
something doesn't quite fit or the data
is not very good it can be very
challenging for your automated routine
to really determine what it is you're
looking at so the reason we turn to the
Internet is because we just need more
people we need more human brains and so
what we've built through the Zooniverse
to our experience with Galaxy Zoo we've
essentially built the world's largest
distributed supercomputer dedicated to
pattern recognition we've linked up over
300,000 human brains and turned it into
a a science machine when we launched the
original Galaxy Zoo we thought that
maybe there's a few dozen no 100 or
maybe for really lucky a few thousand
people across the internet who'd be
interested in doing this and so our
expectations for how long it would take
us to sort through a million galaxies
we're very low we thought it would take
many years to do this and instead when
we launched the website in 2007 within a
few hours so many people had logged on
wanting to classify galaxies that it
actually melted one of our service and
the website was knocked offline so
Galaxy Zoo has been a huge success over
a span of almost two years every single
one of these 1 million galaxies has been
viewed more than 70 times by the
galaxies who uses we think it will be
great to involve citizen scientists in
this project it'll be sort of man
against machine and it's a great
experiment to see how well human beings
can do the human brain is incredible at
pattern recognition so we think that
against the background of these vary
wildly varying light curves with spots
and everything else that you'll be able
to pick out tiny transit events with
planet hunters citizen scientists will
be able to evaluate one of these light
curves in a matter of seconds we'll ask
you to do three things the first step is
check to see if there's an offset in the
data a sort of glitch and let us know
about that so we can go in and fix it
the second question will be is a star
variable do you does the light look sort
of scattered but constant or do you see
cyclical variations in the star that
have periods of days or months perhaps
and then the third question we'll ask
you to actually try and flag any transit
events that you see so if you see a
series of low points a little like
raining almost these look like raindrops
falling down then we'll ask you to draw
a box around these points and flag it as
a prospective transit
the excitement over Kepler is incredible
because we're pretty sure that in the
next two or three years we're going to
quadruple the number of planets that
have been found and more importantly
we're going to be finding planets that
are closer to Earth the size of Earth
rather than gas giant planets like
Jupiter or Saturn or even Neptune so for
citizen scientists the treasure hunt is
clearly going to be trying to find the
smallest transit events possible and the
planets that are going to be the most
difficult to find are going to be the
smallest planets and the planets that
have longer orbital periods these are
planets are farther away from their host
stars so the point of citizen science is
not to provide entertainment or just
provide education the point of citizen
science is to actively involve people in
real research so when you join planet
hunters and he go look at light curves
of stars in our Milky Way and
investigate them you're contributing to
actual sites and might make an actual
discovery
you